apple just released the 6 000
graphics card for their mac pro this is
their w6900x
it is a special graphics card because it
is an mpx module so it passes through
thunderbolt and has 32 gigabytes of
video memory which is huge so today
let's see how it performs and isn't
really worth that price tag compared to
the cheaper option now if you guys
didn't see last time when i unboxed the
6800x i had a huge surprise where they
put the wrong label on the card it got
me thinking that i just got a killer
deal but unfortunately when i looked at
and connected it it was not so i have
one that's mislabeled 6900x and an
actual 6900x so we're going to test out
some gaming benchmarks raw graphics
performance 3d rendering video editing
and some really difficult ak pro res raw
to see how this thing performs the first
question i have after last week's
incident is is this actually the
graphics card that it's labeled with so
let's go ahead and take a look alright
yes it is the correct one that is
labeled on the box so that is good it
was a bummer last time but as you guys
may know with these high-end graphics
cards you usually run into diminishing
returns so let's go ahead and start out
with geekbench 5. in the last video i
didn't really get that much of a better
score than the old graphics cards that
the mac pro launched with all right
let's see what we get bam all right
that is a great score 170
692
but that is actually only about 25
better performance than the much less
expensive w 6800
x now of course in the real world the
difference could be much bigger
depending on what you're doing just like
we saw in the previous video where the
metal score wasn't that much bigger
compared to the vega 2 but the 3d
rendering score was much much greater so
next i want to check out basemark's gpu
test this is for modern metal gaming
we're gonna run the quad the default
here just so you guys can compare to
your max at home all right we have a
result of 15
327
for the score now that is once again
about 25 faster than the other graphics
card so right out of the gate it seems
like you're paying almost double the
money for 25 more performance that does
not seem like a good deal but what i'm
very curious about is how does this
score right here compared to just buying
a regular desktop 6900 xt that you can
buy on the market for probably have to
price maybe even less even with those
inflated numbers so let's go ahead and
compare i know the other graphics card
was slower than the general one you can
buy how is this one comparison down
clocked or does it perform great and
here we go it looks like this one is not
down clocked compared to the w6800x
we have this have almost the same score
compared to before where there was a
2000 point jump between the regular one
you could put in a pc so this one does
perform better which is a good thing now
of course these cards here that are less
expensive they don't have 32 gigs of
video memory and they are consumer
versions not the pro line which is more
expensive now the next test i want to
run is blender we're gonna go ahead and
get started here this is where we saw a
massive difference with these new big
navi cards compared to the previous
generation so let's see how this one
does and we have a result and it looks
like we have five minutes and 51 seconds
now
that is way faster close to three times
faster compared to the vega 2 uh which
was a crazy car that's what i currently
own
but compared to the 6800 x that actually
once again comes in at 25 faster
right around there so very consistent so
far
now what i'm really curious about we're
seeing this result here how does a 6 000
graphics card compare to the 1 000 w
5700 x and with that how does this
compare to an m1 mac mini which with 16
gigs of ram you can buy for just 900
bucks compared to 6 grand for this card
is this thing just a ripoff so that's
actually a video that i'm going to be
making to see how all this compares if
you guys want to see that click that
subscribe button down below and with
that you can help us reach our goal of a
million subscribers before the end of
the year that would be awesome so enough
with the benchmarks let's get into real
world programs to see if this beast can
help us out much more than with those
tests here i have a one minute 4k clip
encoded in hevc and we're going to see
how fast this thing can be stabilized
final cut has gotten really efficient
and this graphics card has a lot of
muscle so let's go ahead and click
stabilize i'll start my timer
and it looks like it is off
going super fast here
interestingly the graphics usage is
almost nothing what is that all right
that was done right there before i tell
you guys the time i want to see how much
of the gpu was actually used did we see
that little spike right there i mean
that is realistically like five percent
or so
as far as memory memories use about 25
so even though it did that in eight
seconds flat yeah a minute a 4k footage
stabilized in eight seconds compared to
10 about 20 percent improvement there
not much uh it barely used any of these
resources so it looks like this is just
way overkill and if you're like me you
stabilize five second clicks 10 seconds
it's basically instant now instead i
have no weight for a long time like
before of course playing back 4k footage
with lots color corrections film grain
applied it is no issue for this graphics
card look at that seven percent usage
cpus also seven eight percent it is
nothing this is the only easy test i'm
going to throw at this and then we're
going to get to the hard stuff but i
still want to see if this thing can
export this any faster so doing this
video right now the usage went up by a
little bit 9
on the graphics card 14 on the cpu and
that is it this is nothing for this
computer and bam
we are finished that is by far the
fastest time i've ever seen actually i
shouldn't say by far that is the fastest
time i've ever seen for this project but
it is only two seconds faster than the
other graphics card it's it doesn't
really matter this right here is 4k
prores raw with sharpening color
correction
applied
it's playing back in slow motion is
actually 4k 120 and it's playing back
perfectly smoothly if we take a look
this is just laughable 12 graphics card
usage that is it that just shows how
much overhead how much extra performance
we have to do multi-cam with this to
stack it or even say to move up to 8k
footage so right here i have 8k pro as
well it's actually for 4ks but you can't
just magically encode you can't just
encode it yourself so when you stack it
this is the ak timeline and even here
look at that perfectly smoothly no issue
and this actually without the
afterburner card i actually sold that to
somebody that really needed it
because i did not and without it it's
playing back perfectly 14
graphics usage
what the heck so can you do 16k multiple
streams that is crazy let's go ahead and
export this and this time i'm not going
to be exporting to
h.264 or h.265 we're going to go to
prores so we're not going to be limited
by the encoders i'm really excited to
see how this is gonna perform we have a
five minute project here let's hit start
bam
okay guys
this has got to be a joke
this has to be a joke let's clear this
go ahead and take a look at this right
here
when we look at the gpu processor usage
look at that i was exporting that
a 4k pro reservoir to progress
look at the gp usage six percent four
percent five percent
that's this graphics card now this
little spike
right over here you see this right here
we're looking at 64
75
this was me running the same exact test
on the 6800x
right before this video
this graphics card has so much extra
performance that is not used that it
went from 60 70
down to six and four percent graphics
usage exporting that same project that
is
that is just insane and the results here
are exactly the same two minutes and 37
seconds as before for this five minute
project so it's not the limitation at
all
the graphics card is just sitting there
barely being used when we're exporting
this footage let's go ahead and just try
out this 8k and this time i'm going to
export it to pro res 4 four four four
q
x this is the one that is the highest
quality you can possibly get all right
so now we have a difference we're
looking at 13 minutes and 51 seconds
compared to 16 minutes and 40 seconds
with the previous one so not quite 25
percent faster probably about 20 percent
or so so at least we have a difference
but once again the graphics card wasn't
being used that much uh let's go ahead
and do another test that i didn't do
before this is modern canon r5 footage
the new codec that nukes most of these
computers other than the m1 i want to
see if it can perform any better let's
hit play
and
look at that just as i expected as i
told you guys when apple announced this
this 6 000 graphics card cannot play
this back or the cpu even though we're
only at 23 cp usage it just can't deal
with this file it is a pain where the m1
it is smooth like butter thanks to apple
engineering uh but with this case you
have to transcode it so let's see how
long that takes it looks like the same
exact 30 minutes as we did before that's
because it's limited to the cpu and even
though it's not using the whole cpu it's
just very inefficient whereas the m1 mac
mini but i'll save that for that actual
video so let's go ahead and see how long
it takes to export this project maybe
for that it'll be a little faster okay
so it is a little faster 6 minutes and
50 seconds compared to 7 minutes and 15
seconds definitely not worth the price
jump from 2800
up to 6 000. i presume the same thing is
going to happen with canon cinema raw
light footage as far as playback of
course no issue and look at that we're
only at 13 graphics 12 graphics
scrolling through crazy smoothly with
color corrections applied no issues
there we have four minutes and 30
seconds compared to four minutes and 35
seconds so not really an improvement
let's just go ahead and skip the 4.5 k
row let's throw 8k
red raw added now the last graphics card
i know that one couldn't play it back
perfectly smoothly let's go ahead and
check it out here this is ak footage raw
in an ak timeline playing back at 8k
look at that
still a tiny stutter every once in a
while graphic skirts finally being taken
advantage of all right now it looks
pretty smooth that looks good right
there looks like we had one at the start
now it's playing back perfectly smoothly
all right so that's good let's go ahead
and see how this works and we're going
to skip the encoders go straight to
prores we have six minutes the same
exact time as with the cheaper graphics
card so there you guys go as far as raw
performance we saw about a 25
improvement both in regular metal gaming
some other tests 20 and others and in a
lot of these pretty much no difference
whatsoever now where can this graphics
card fit in who should buy it
well i mean maybe somebody if they need
as much performance as they can and they
don't care about money at all then maybe
but you don't have any other advantages
no extra displays you don't have any
extra video memory anything like that
and there's also the 6800x duo card
which gives you two graphics cards in
one which should have more performance
for applications that could take
advantage of like final cut and that
costs less money as well so is apple's 6
000 graphics card worth it well for most
people even high-end professionals no
not really now what i'm wondering is how
do these scores compare to the m1 i
haven't done a lot of these and of
course to the much cheaper
w5700x which costs a thousand bucks or
it's a 600 upgrade is it gonna be close
is that actually the one to buy but
we'll have another video you guys can
comment down below let me know what
other tests should i run that are much
more difficult i'm thinking maybe some
denoising
something else that's tough let me know
down below so i can put it into that
masterful video that's gonna have a lot
of details click that circle above to
subscribe and help us reach 1 million
subscribers before the end of the year
we would greatly appreciate it check out
one of those great videos over there
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]